Такий заголовок у німецькій газеті ще донедавна
важко було уявити. "Ми його заарештуємо".
Так міністр юстиції Німеччини Марко Бушманн в інтерв'ю Bild
прокоментував рішення Міжнародного кримінального суду
про видачу ордера на арешт президента Росії.
На урядових пресконференціях в Берліні тема арешту Путіна
цими днями - одна з головних.
Канцлер вже однозначно висловився з цього приводу.
Він уже говорив, що нікому не дозволено стояти вище
права і закону. Це дуже важливий принцип міжнародного права.
І всі знають, що Міжнародний кримінальний суд -
це важлива міжнародна інстанція, місія якої регулюється
міжнародними договорами. Військові злочинці повинні відповідати
перед судом, їм не можна дозволити ніде почуватися у безпеці,
і це правило поширюється і на російського президента також.
Представник МЗС Німеччини не вважає, що ордер на арешт
якось вплине на деескалацію в Україні.
Ми вже неодноразово зазначали, що дипломатії та спроб переговорів
не бракує. Чого не вистачає, то це готовності президента Росії
вивести свої війська з України та закінчити війну.
Однак для німецьких фахівців з міжнародного права все не так
однозначно. Юристи нагадують, що Росія не має зобов'язань
у рамках кримінального суду.
Якщо теоретично Путін приїхав би до Німеччини,
то проблема була б у тому, що він як президент РФ
має особистий імунітет у рамках міжнародного права.
І питання в тому, чи не розповсюджується цей особистий
імунітет на випадок, коли Путін розшукується за ордером
на арешт Міжнародного кримінального суду.
На цих архівних кадрах візит Путіна до Берліна влітку 2018 року.
Тодішня канцлерка країни Анґела Меркель приймала його
в урядовій резиденції у передмісті Берліна.
Судячи з останніх заяв уряду ФРН, це може стати останньою поїздкою
російського лідера до Німеччини.
Реакція Москви на заяву міністра юстиції про готовність
заарештувати Путіна була різко негативною.
Посол Росії у ФРН Сергій Нечаєв заявив, що безвідповідальні
заяви деяких німецьких офіційних осіб про готовність
виконати нелегітимне і абсолютно абсурдне рішення
Міжнародного кримінального суду викликають крайнє занепокоєння
і свідчать, наскільки далекі вони від реальності
у прагненні подальшої ескалації конфлікту з Росією.
Тим часом український президент Володимир Зеленський
назвав рішення про видачу ордера на арешт Путіна історичним,
з якого нарешті почнеться історична відповідальність.
В історії міжнародного права вже були ордери на арешт
глав держав. І більшість із фігурантів рано чи пізно
постали перед судом у Гаазі.
Це і Слободан Мілошевич, і Чарльз Тейлор.
В історії МКС був один ордер невиконаний,
це ордер щодо Омара Башира, досі не виконаний.
І постали перед судом кілька глав держав, хто добровільно з'явився.
Це кенійський президент Кеніато.
Загалом, звісно, ситуація така, що в Міжнародному суді
опиняються колишні глави держав.
Міжнародний кримінальний суд визнав, що перспективи
виконання ордера на арешт Путіна мало залежать від самого суду.
Згідно з Римським статутом - документом, який підписують країни,
які визнають юрисдикцію МКС - держава повинна сама
видати підозрюваного Гаазі.
Росія Римський статут не ратифікувала та оголосила,
що юрисдикцію Міжнародного кримінального суду не визнає.
Нинішнє, фактично, перше рішення палати суддів у справі,
пов'язаній з російською агресією в Україні, ухвалено лише за фактами
незаконної примусової депортації українських дітей
з окупованих Росією територій.
Звинувачення полягає в тому, що дітей вивозили літаками,
поїздами, наземним транспортом у Росію та віддавали на усиновлення.
Відповідні правові норми ухвалено указом президента.
Їх навчали не українською, а російською мовою,
і вони, ймовірно, були прийняті в російське громадянство.
Це є явним порушенням четвертої Женевської конвенції.
Але чому лише через депортацію дітей і чому саме зараз?
Це свого роду попередження про злочинність
вчинених діянь, вважають експерти.
Те, що саме з цієї теми розпочав Міжнародний кримінальний суд,
це якраз дуже зрозуміло. Дуже зрозуміло і по-людськи, і юридично.
Ці речі, які стосуються питань незворотних порушень,
розглядаються насамперед. Чому ми говоримо про екстрені заходи
щодо незворотного порушення прав людини, коли йдеться про дітей?
Вони зростають, і вони формуються.
Це справді дуже серйозне порушення, це злочин,
який можна вважати одним із найтяжчих.
Ордерів поки два: один на арешт Путіна,
другий на арешт уповноваженої з прав дитини
при президентові РФ Марії Львової-Бєлової.
У телеграм-каналі уповноваженої регулярно з'являлися відео,
де вона супроводжує дітей з окупованих територій до Росії.
Ось вона поїздом у квітні 2022 року з групою дітей,
а тут у вересні - на літаку, разом з нею 125 дітей з Донецької області.
Ласкаво просимо в Москву.
30 травня 2022 року Путін підписав указ, який спростив процедуру
надання громадянства дітям з окупованих територій,
а також процес їхнього усиновлення.
Ідеться про підопічних дитячих будинків, дітей, які були у лікарнях
чи таборах відпочинку, дітей, яких забирали разом із батьками
та розлучали під час так званої "фільтрації".
Наразі повернути в Україну вдалося лише 126 дітей.
Європейські журналісти розслідували низку фактів
примусової депортації дітей та поговорили з тими,
кого вдалося повернути.
Нас посадили на КАМАЗи і повезли у фільтраційний табір.
Там маму допитували, а потім сказали, що мама фільтрацію
не пройшла і що мене від неї забирають.
Вони навіть попрощатися не дали.
І приїхала Новоазовська служба у справах дітей і сказали,
що вони мене від мами забирають.
І потім я казав росіянам, що в мене є бабуся, я знаю її номер.
А вони казали: "Та ти нікому не потрібний. У тебе буде нова сім'я".
Я вірю, що я її знайду, і вона приїде сюди.
Я нічого не буду казати, я обійму її.
13-річну Карину, доньку Наталії з Козачої Лопані,
забрали під час окупації прямо з літнього табору неподалік будинку.
- Ви думаєте, Росія хоче залишити у себе дітей?
- Так. Так.
Тому що половина тих, хто поїхав, повиїжджав вночі,
вони вже роблять там російські паспорти і залишаються там.
Сюди їм, як їм сказали, наче не дозволяють в'їжджати,
але я в це не вірю.
Понад 16 тисяч дітей вивезли до Росії з окупованих українських територій,
стверджують у Києві. Це офіційні дані на початок лютого цього року.